south africa's governing party the
african national congress has been
plagued by internal divisions for years
a poorly performing economy a lack of
service delivery and allegations of
corruption have added to a decline in
support
this conference
has demonstrated more clearly
that
more than ever before
our common commitment to lead our
organization of
fictionalism
patronage and corruption
and to renew and
to rebuild our organization
is quite
an urgent mission
critics blame the party's leaders for
failing to address some of south
africa's challenges despite three
decades of democracy inequality is rife
and many poor communities still don't
have access to running water and
electricity president ramaphosa says
fraud and corruption are to blame but
his efforts to end the scourge have been
weakened by a corruption scandal
he's been accused of concealing the
theft of four million dollars from his
game farm there are massive global
forces that have to be taken into
account but mal administration poor
management of the economy particularly
in the state-owned enterprises
not doing what was actually indicated by
anc governments in the late 1990s around
securing the energy sector um having a
better education system at both basic
and tertiary level to ensure that people
are employable and to transform social
space as well as the economy so that
more people find ownership in it to
broaden the tax base none of these
things have been done the conference
aimed to come up with solutions to some
of the most urgent problems including
unemployment of 35 percent and rising
poverty but it's not expected the anc
will immediately resolve any of these
key challenges and instead will put
forward recommendations to be discussed
later familia miller al jazeera
johannesburg